we don't want to just be talking in an
echo chamber here we don't want to be
pyromaniacs in a field of straw man and
so we we sometimes invite left-wingers
on the show to present the strongest
version of their point of view i'm
always very grateful
when left-wingers come on the show not
an easy thing to do most most of them
just refuse to do it so i'm very pleased
that our guest is bronte remzik who is a
third year medical student a social
activist uh very much in support of
legal abortion we've gone back and forth
on tick tock and twitter and myspace and
all sorts of social media platforms
so we thought let's just have her on the
show and discuss the issue bronte thank
you so much for coming on
hi michael i can't say that it's a
pleasure but i'm excited to help you
expand your perspective well that's very
kind of you to do that so bronte before
we get to the issue of abortion itself
which i suspect we will get to
i guess we have to get to this issue
that anna kasparian raised and that is
really at the heart of this supreme
court decision in the past week of the
news cycle namely
does the constitution enshrine a right
to abortion it seems very difficult to
argue that it does one because i don't
see that right anywhere the judges who
decided that there was a right in 1973
a right that previously had never been
acknowledged in the constitution they
said that it was found within the
emanations and the penumbras and they
couldn't quite point to exactly where it
was but hey anyway it's there then you
had planned parenthood vkc in the early
1990s which actually overruled part of
roe versus wade at least in the argument
for why we needed legal abortion but
nevertheless upheld legal abortion and
it was all
kind of just a big jumbled mess so is it
your position that the constitution
provides for some heretofore invisible
right to an abortion regardless of what
you think about the issue
it is my opinion that we have a right to
privacy and abortion is a medical
procedure and the right to privacy does
extend to the discussions between a
patient and a medical provider okay but
i could have a right to privacy with my
mafia capo and we could decide to whack
my political enemy and those i guess
those conversations would be private i
don't think there is some generalized
right to privacy in the constitution but
even if they were that would have no
bearing on the life of the person that
we're going to kill right
well the discussion between you and your
mafia friend is very different from a
discussion between a patient and a
medical provider we have laws that
protect patient privacy for this exact
reason but but i suppose you're right
the distinction is that right now it's
illegal for me to talk to my mafia boss
and call out a hit on someone i don't
like and it is legal right now at least
according to the civil law for a woman
to talk to a doctor and kill her child
but that very likely will not remain
legal if roe vs weight is overturned in
13 14 states instantly that will become
illegal so i guess i'm just talking
about the matter itself beyond questions
of the civil law which might be changing
in real time right now
what's the difference if if you're
saying it's all about a right to privacy
i'm saying no it's it's about the baby
that's being killed so
do you have an answer for that or are we
just denying the humanity of the baby
no absolutely so when you put up a
scenario of trying to put out a hit
with the mafia you are talking about
murdering a born living conscious
sentient autonomous person when we talk
about abortion we are talking about
ending a
non-autonomous life it does you do not
have the right to bodily autonomy if you
are not autonomous and if you are a
fetus prior to the limit of viability
you do not have autonomy therefore you
do not have the right to bodily autonomy
this is a great one
you reside inside of the body of an
autonomous person and the right to
bodily autonomy allows you to refuse to
use your body to support the life of
another person so
this is a precise and important point
you've made you've acknowledged that
abortion ends a life but you've said
those were your exact words you just
said that the life is not autonomous
would you say that a uh
two-day-old post-birth baby is
autonomous
it is it has bodily autonomy and it's
able its body system is able to function
autonomously yes
the baby can feed itself
you are trying to get to the point where
they require external resources but any
person can provide that infant external
resources the utilization of someone's
internal organs is very different from
providing external resources you cannot
force someone to be a parent and provide
external resources you can give up that
child at any point that you stop
consenting to your parental
responsibilities and your parental
rights okay so this that's fine so so
we've acknowledged now that the baby is
is living in the womb or outside the
womb it's a living being and that the
baby is
it's not really auton and maybe it has
it it's not attached by an umbilical
cord but it certainly doesn't have
autonomy when it's two days old it needs
to it needs to eat it needs everything
taken care of for it what you're saying
is though once the umbilical cord has
been severed the baby can be taken care
of by someone else so then my question
is
why would we not merely encourage
adoption if the mother feels she can't
take care of the baby why not just give
up the baby for adoption rather than
killing the baby in the womb
because pregnancy and itself is a very
serious medical condition that has
physical mental emotional and financial
burdens for the pregnant person and to
force a person to endure that experience
against their will is simply immoral and
it's belittling the experience that
pregnancy is well so when you say
against their will what you are you're
referring to cases of rape basically
right because when you engage in sex you
are engaging in an act of the will the
consequence of which is historically
speaking always pregnancy
correct but when you consent to sex
you're not consenting to pregnancy you
are consenting to the possibility of
pregnancy but you can think of it like
this you can think of it like this you
understand the difference between
consensual sex and sexual sexual assault
you should then understand the
difference between wanted pregnancy and
unwanted pregnancy technically
physically they are the same thing but
when your body is being used against
your will and without your consent those
are very different experiences for the
person but
you you've just acknowledged that when
you consent to sex you are consenting to
the possibility of pregnancy so
there you have it there you are you have
consented to that now you might not want
to become pregnant you might want to use
all sorts of contraceptives and things
like that but surely
i mean you've just said it yourself
you're consenting to that possibility
and so now you're telling me that if one
wants to then withdraw one's consent
because one doesn't want to be
uncomfortable for some matter of months
you're saying that the the better
alternative is to just kill the baby
whom you have acknowledged is alive
first of all calling pregnancy simply
discomfort is belittling the experience
but you can always
can men become pregnant or no
if you have a uterus
a man with a uterus
look i'm not a biologist so i'm not sure
if i'll become pregnant i do have a
little emoji that tells me that these
days men can become pregnant regardless
regardless of that
if you're talking about non-consensual
sex what percentage of pregnancies arise
from rape incest or involve a threat to
the life of the mother well it's hard to
say because about three quarters of
sexual assault go unreported so any
statistic that i would give to you is
going to be inherently an act i'll give
you a statistic a statistic from the the
most left-wing source i can give the
guttmacher institute it's the think tank
for planned parenthood less than one
percent of abortions take place because
of rape ancestor pose a threat to the
life of the mother so we're talking
about it extraordinarily the ones that
have been reported according to the ones
that have been reported don't you think
don't you think if there were don't you
think if there were a scarier statistic
that the most pro abortion organization
in the country might use those
statistics
but these statistics are very difficult
to collect because again sexual assault
is a difficult issue when people don't
often report them because you see how
our political system doesn't often
support victims of sexual assault and so
if our system doesn't support people
reporting sexual assault therefore it is
underreported so this seems difficult
for me bronte well one i it seems that
in the years after the metoo movement
there is quite a great political impulse
to report sexual assault and all sorts
of sexual issues but furthermore you're
telling me that we need to rely on these
statistics trust the science trust the
public health organizations when it's
convenient for your argument and
convenient for abortion but we shouldn't
trust this statistics when it's
inconvenient for your argument argument
and supports the pro-life argument
that is incorrect you simply don't
understand how these statistics work and
how they are collected when you
understand when you now analyze
statistics you have to understand the
bias and the flaws that they have and
what you are specifically citing
statistics that have inherent flaws that
doesn't mean that all of the statistics
that we cite are inherently flawed you
have to understand the issue at hand and
how those statistics are collected okay
fair enough so so you're saying you just
you don't believe these statistics that
are inconvenient but you say you have
perfectly good reason not to believe the
statistics i suppose the question though
is really beyond the statistics isn't it
if you are acknowledging bronte that
the baby is alive if you are
acknowledging that the baby could be
given up for adoption if you are
acknowledging that instances of rape are
i think we can acknowledge they're quite
rare at least when we're talking about
even if you dispute some of the
statistics they're they're the exception
not the rule
if you are acknowledging all sorts of if
you are acknowledging the relatively low
maternal mortality rate if you are
acknowledging
the advancements in science if you are
acknowledging that very very few women
die every year from illegal abortions
and uh all sorts of the other scare
statistics that come out if you're
acknowledging all of those numbers even
beyond that
don't don't we still have the fact of
the baby don't we still have the
non-utilitarian non-statistical simple
fact that you're talking about a living
human being
no so first off you said that we have a
low mortality rate which actually we
have one of the highest maternal
mortality rates amongst all of the
developed countries but it's still quite
what's what is the maternal mortality
right according to this i don't know it
off the top of my head 20 20 out of 100
000 and that and that includes
communities that do not have very good
public health outcomes because of
various behaviors and pathologies in the
community so it's relatively quite low
how many women died from illegal
abortion the year before roe versus wade
i'm not sure but that's besides the
point 39 women how many women died from
legal abortion the year before roe
versus wade
i think what you're misunderstanding is
that death is not the only negative
outcome of pregnancy just because you
don't die does not mean that your life
and your body is not impacted for the
rest of your life because a lot of
people are left with chronic pain and
your body is [ __ ] functionally and
structurally altered and so death is not
the most accurate statistic to determine
whether or not pregnancy is a negative
experience there there we go so so we we
move past the question of death and we
say well really it's forget about death
for a second it's just that it's it's
very uncomfortable and not only
uncomfortable for nine months it might
be uncomfortable for the rest of your
life or it might change your body
chemistry it might change the way you
look or it might change
is any of that bronte i'll leave you
with this because i know we're way over
the time is any of that an argument now
that we've kind of chipped away i i
think at least it's up for the viewers
to decide chipped away at the
constitutional argument or the legal
argument or the statistical argument or
the argument for mortality now we get
down to well it's just i just don't like
what it does to my body is that an
argument bronte for killing a human
being who you admit is alive
absolutely everyone has the right to
determine the status of their body they
have the right to decide when and how
their body is used and if you would like
to go back to i know that you've had a
lot to say about vaccines and masks so i
don't think it's very confusing for you
to understand when you are concerned
about certain effects that certain
things might have on your body someone
has every right to decide whether or not
they consent to that
my only issue with the masks and all the
covid stuff is that it's very silly and
disordered but i'm not not even making
some sort of maximal bodily autonomy
argument regardless though i think
they're a little different because we're
acknowledging the baby so so i would i
guess i would leave you with this
thought from naomi wolfe uh well
well-known feminist uh made this point
in the 1990s she said that what the
pro-abortion movement needs to be able
to do
is defend abortion and she
was and i think still may be a defender
of abortion she said we need to defend
abortion by acknowledging
the baby the unborn baby we need to say
that the unborn baby is a baby stop
pretending he's not a human stop
pretending he's not alive acknowledge
that he's a baby and say that for women
to be equal they must be able to kill
the baby in all of his humanity would
you agree with that statement
what i agree with is that in order to
protect and value an unborn non-viable
non-sentient life no bodies
actively devalue and dehumanize the
pregnant person you cannot pretend to
protect unborn life without actively
dehumanizing and devaluing the pregnant
person and removing their bodily
autonomy and that is the issue at hand
it seems to me when we treat women as
mothers we are valuing them it's i don't
think it's i think it's devaluing women
to use them for sex and try to avoid the
consequences of sex by killing the baby
and then pretending it's somehow
legitimate because the baby is not
sentient so as though we could kill
someone in a coma or as though someone
who were asleep the baby were not
particularly conscious as though we
could kill people who had mental
disabilities i don't think any of those
arguments really work and i think i
think the issue that's at heart here is
that you are suggesting that uh women
being used as vessels for sexual
pleasure
without dealing with the consequences of
sex namely the
creation of human beings that that is
somehow more liberating and more
empowering than women coming together
in love and giving that love with a man
to a human being i think that's what it
really comes down i find it interesting
that whenever you talk about women
having sex you say that we are used and
that proves the fact no not whenever not
whenever only no no only in your version
of it not not in i don't think women
should be used for sexual incorrect it
does it seems like men still believe
that sex is something that they do to
women and not no no
you must have misheard me bronte i said
that men and women no i i i don't think
i did but that's up for the listeners to
decide i said that the the more valuing
liberating flourishing view of sex is
that men and women come together because
they are complementary they love one
another they join together in marriage
and they create new human life and
that's a beautiful miraculous wonderful
thing and i think that the the view of
the pro-abortion movement
is that women ought to be used as uh
merely vessels for sexual pleasure and
with with and out of accountability such
that if there is a product of love or
maybe not so much love
namely a child that comes out of that
sexual union that that baby ought to be
killed i think that's a devaluing of
women rather than evaluating or a
liberation
minimizing women's value to the role of
motherhood is simply misogynistic
minimizing i think that's maximizing
frankly i think i think i think the
universe world view which is obviously
flawed well i don't know we were both
born of mothers and i'm quite happy for
that value that was added to my life and
i'm very happy that my mother consented
to the pregnancy that brought me forth
but i would never want my mother to
bring me into the world against her will
all right i i i mean yeah i i don't
think that uh
i don't think our discussion of will or
value or any of those things i i
i think it has boiled down to this this
particular
point of of what the body is for right i
mean isn't that kind of what we're
talking about here is is our body for is
sex for
the
maximal
individual pursuit of pleasure or is it
for something else is it for a baby is
it for
a unit of love is it for something
beyond just our own desires
your body is whatever you want it to be
used for that is the basis of consent
and bodily autonomy you cannot decide
what the use and value of someone's body
is for them and that is the root of the
pro-choice stance what about what about
the body of the baby in in the abortion
baby when the baby lacks autonomy and it
requires the body of an autonomous
person in order to live that autonomous
person must exercise their bodily
autonomy and at any point they must
consent to supporting that possible life
must exercise all right i'm way over as
usual bronte but i listen i really
appreciate your coming on uh it's uh
takes takes a lot of husband i know
there's a lot of sexual confusion these
days but it takes gojones to come on a
conservative show and discuss the issue
uh i i hope that uh as you think about
this issue and stew on it some more that
uh your eyes are open to the reality of
the situation but i i appreciate your
coming on in any case bronte ramsey
where can people find you
absolutely they can find me on tick tock
at bronte remsik i also have my website
is behind and curious.com all right
thank you bronte appreciate it
i'm glad you like that clip now ring the
bell subscribe get all those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you